meine eltern wollten wissen wie man
urlaub war deswegen habe ich dieses
video für die aufgenommen endlich
gefällt
[Musik]
hallo mein name ist supernett ich
willkommen leute seinem neuen video ist
und ich bin ja in köln bonn hervor ich
mich heute mit dem kollegen nach
teneriffa
ich würde sagen wieder wollte story wir
sind am flughafen angekommen wie man
ganz kurz fasnet den ich gemacht habe
die analysten waren schlichte kritik
durch sagt alles über passt eigentlich
nur vor abflug jahren und andere zwei
leuten lassen ein bisschen sagen ihr
seid bestimmt wer kommt versteht die
welt nicht mehr mitfliegen auf jeden
fall heute ich die preise eigentlich
nicht bloggen weil sein zeit urlaub ist
immer sie sein sollte
wir halten morgen um vier uhr nachts von
düsseldorf weeze nach teneriffa und war
dann um 48 stunden alles vergessen
[Musik]
sehr gutes
der rest werde ich eine wunderschöne
kleine küche es sind gerade relativ
angenehme 21 grad mit einem leichten
lauf westen sind wir haben schöne sonne
auf jeden fall auch am start eigentlich
wurde vorher komplett bewölkt
vorhergesagt aber seitdem ich heiser
kern in dieser stadt geworden
[Musik]
niedrig
also wir waren gerade am strand ich
blende euch jetzt gerade noch kein bild
ein aber schaut euch einfach meinen
konnten rand an
wir waren zwei stunden am strand
mir tut alles weh und jetzt fahren so
naturpool wir sind jetzt gerade bei
diesen klippen angekommen allerdings ist
das problem dass man irgendwie nicht auf
die drauf kann da oben wollten
also leute tolle sache gerne greift das
lindert hochschulpfarrer sind sogar das
nun unterwegs und hat sich in den
verdammten wollte da vorne selber folgen
die sind auf der gleichen höhe mit den
wolken
[Musik]
dettelbach und verfolgt leider vorne
fall die wellen gegen die beine die
anzahl dahinten es irgendeine andere
insel
[Musik]
nur ein sprecher
geöffnet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier sind wir wieder kurz zurück und
hälfte war nach dem frühstück weil ich
jetzt gerade ein neues video hochgeladen
habe und wir eben auch noch ganz gut in
sachen gepackt haben wir gehen jetzt auf
jeden fall wieder an strand aber ich
werde jetzt halt nicht gewährte kamera
hin mitnehmen sondern mit myphone film
wir sind jetzt gerade am strand
angekommen mitbringen
frank formulare wir werden jetzt alle zu
erkunden weil das war gar nicht gemacht
haben und danach wieder eine strandbar
städten hätte mir geholt war von dem
schmidt
[Musik]
nachdem er ist gerade am strand lagen
wir verteilten gegangen und haben uns
ins bett gelegt wollten nur schilder war
kam dann irgendwie gepennt und jetzt bin
ich voll probleme verlaufen doch
kurzzeitig gemacht es ist kalt geworden
draußen sind es auch ein pulli an wir
werden jetzt eine strandpromenade gehen
und wir haben auf geräten sollte derzeit
echt kalt deswegen jemand wirklich im
hotelzimmer aber der sonnenuntergang
auch wenn das heute nicht mehr weit ist
schon ganz nah
[Musik]
wir frühstücken gerade halt sehen und es
ist heute unfassbar ganz besser aber wir
fliegen in zwei stunden zurück hier
zähle gerade whirlpool und da vorne
[Musik]
wir waren jetzt cool und werden jetzt
auch ein bisschen sie am vorliegen und
und wann wo eine halbe stunde auf dem
flughafen machen
[Musik]
ich bin wieder zu hause in meiner
wohnung angekommen und wird jetzt auch
sagen dass sie mit diesem blog von
diesem sehr chaotischen und komischen
aber trotzdem den meisten holt jetzt war
wenn ich das ganze video gefallen hat
was gerne mal ein like da ich weiß
letzte block weil ich mir die ganze zeit
geführt wird von der kamera zum iphone
und weiter und fordern trotzdem gefallen
[Musik]